Hey there, Will Arnett here. Welcome to SmartLess, our podcast, where Jason Babin, Sean Hayes and I, each week one of us brings a guest that the other two don't know about. And this week is no exception. We get real into it. Most of the time we just mess around with each other and then the guest has to be embarrassed. So let's get right to the podcast.
Hi. Hi. How are you? Good, good. Should we go around the room and just say our names and our roles?
Introduce yourself?
Yeah, I'm Sean Hayes.
People have been listening to the podcast for a minute now.
Sorry, so we just skip that.
Same three idiots.
Okay.
大家好，我是威尔·阿奈特。欢迎收听我们的播客节目《SmartLess》。每周，我和杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海斯三个人中，都会有一人带来一位另外两人事先都不知道的神秘嘉宾。这周也不例外。我们总是玩得很真。大多数时候，我们只是互相调侃，然后让嘉宾感到尴尬。那么，我们直接进入播客吧。嗨。嗨。你好吗？很好，很好。我们要不要围着屋子报一下各自的名字和角色？介绍一下你自己？好吧，我是肖恩·海斯。大家听这个播客已经有一会儿了。抱歉，那我们就跳过这个吧。还是那三个笨蛋。好吧。
In the role of Sean Hayes is Sean Hayes.
Should we switch parts today?
Oh, we could switch parts.
Ooh, yeah.
I'll play will.
What about that?
I'll play well.
扮演肖恩·海斯的是肖恩·海斯。我们今天要不要换一下角色？哦，我们可以换角色。哦，好啊。我来演威尔。我来演威尔。那样怎么样？我来演威尔。
You guys are assholes.
You both want to play me?
I just don't know a question.
You'll answer a question.
single one decade
Fuck
Oh God
Okay
你们俩真混蛋。你们都想演我？我只是不知道该问什么问题。你会回答一个问题。每一个十年来着？操，哦，天哪，好吧。
I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be Jason
So I was
You know
So now listen
It's hard for me though
So when I look back
And I think about all the things that you've done
我要当，我要当杰森。所以我是，你知道的，所以现在听着，对我来说这挺难的。所以当我回想，并想到你所做的一切时……
Let's start at the beginning
Okay so America was founded in 1492
But what if I want to really be understood
No one
No one understands me in my house
You know, I've got a wife and two girls
It just, I start talking they glaze over
So I really have to fight for attention
让我们从头说起。好吧，所以美洲是在1492年被发现的……但是如果我真的想被理解呢？没有人，在我家里没有人理解我。你知道的，我有一个妻子和两个女儿。只要我一开始说话，他们眼神就发直了。所以我真的必须为争取注意力而战。
I get on this thing, I feel like I've got
I can't, I've got to stop describing my question
Right, we've spoken about this before
And I just need to ask the question
And then Sean, and then Sean's like a golden,
Sean comes on and he's like, do you like whipped cream?
The Golden Rich Reader
我一上这个节目，我就觉得我有……我不能，我得停止描述我的问题了。对，我们之前讨论过这个。我只需要问这个问题。然后肖恩，肖恩就像一个金色的，肖恩上来了，他就说，你喜欢鲜奶油吗？金色里奇读者，金色里奇读者。
What's your favorite color?
If Will was a dog, what kind of dog would Will be on this podcast?
Oh, God, that's a good question.
Will's probably like an untrained German shepherd.
But messy, matted.
Yeah, just drool coming out on the sides.
Bad hips like the German shepherds get.
Yeah, dysplasia.
你最喜欢的颜色是什么？如果威尔是一只狗，在这档播客里威尔会是什么品种的狗？哦，天哪，好问题。威尔大概像一只没受过训练的德国牧羊犬。但又乱又脏，毛发打结。对，口水从两边流出来。髋关节不好，就像德国牧羊犬那样。对，髋关节发育不良。
Yeah.
Jesus.
Beaman would be like a full-sized standard but shaved poodle.
So cold yet fancy?
And very proud, walks very proud.
Very proud.
Oh, Lord.
Anyway, let's get to our guest.
对。天哪。比曼就像一只全尺寸的标准狮子狗，不过剃了毛。又高冷又花哨？而且非常骄傲，走路非常骄傲。非常骄傲。哦，天哪。不管怎样，我们来聊聊我们的嘉宾吧。
Please.
Yeah, let's do it.
And I'm going to tell you, you guys actually know this person,
but we're going to find out stuff that we don't know about this person.
If it's my mom, I'm in trouble because I haven't called her for a while.
Can I just say if it's your mom, what?
Careful.
This would be such a...
请吧。对，开始吧。我要告诉你们，你们其实认识这个人，但我们要挖掘一些我们不了解他的事情。如果那是我的妈妈，我就麻烦了，因为我已经有一段时间没给她打电话了。我能说吗，如果那是你妈妈，什么？小心点。这会是一个……
Careful.
No, I'm just going to say it would be such a mitzvah.
If it was your mom, because we could really get into...
There's so much stuff about you, and we've known each other a long time, that I want to know.
You know whose mom is not going to come on? Mine, because she's dead.
That's our first commercial break.
We're going to go to a florist commercial break right now.
Sean, by the way, I will say your mom is dead.
小心点。不，我只是想说这会是一个善举。如果那是你妈妈的话，因为我们可以深入探讨……关于你有很多事情，而且我们认识很久了，我想了解。你知道谁的妈妈不会来吗？我妈，因为她已经去世了。那是我们的第一个商业广告时间。我们现在要进入一个花商的广告时间。顺便说一句，肖恩，我要说你妈已经去世了。
But imagine if my surprise guest was your mom.
That would really, that would be more surprising than me being pale.
Pailer than me, my God.
Guys, our guest today is from Irvine, California.
His mom was a teacher and his father played sax and keyboard for the righteous brothers.
Do we get a chance to guess at any point?
No.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
但想象一下，如果我的神秘嘉宾是你妈妈。那真的会，那比我脸色苍白还要令人惊讶。比我还苍白，天哪。伙计们，我们今天的嘉宾来自加州尔湾。他的妈妈是一名教师，他的爸爸为正义兄弟乐队弹奏萨克斯和键盘。我们有没有机会在某个时候猜一下？没有。哦，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。
No, don't guess because he studied sports journalism at USC,
but ultimately went on to join the groundlings and the rest of his history.
He's got like a million movies under his belt, and I'm sure that's not the only thing.
Ladies and gentlemen, William Farrell.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
Jason.
There's his headshot.
不，不要猜，因为他在南加州大学学习体育新闻，但最终加入了“地面lings”剧团，剩下的就是历史了。他身上有一百万部电影，而且我敢肯定这还不是全部。女士们先生们，威廉·法瑞尔。哦，天哪。哇。杰森。这是他的大头照。
Jason.
Hi, Jason.
Jason, answer the belly.
Jason, it's your mother.
First of all, she's British.
Oh, okay.
But let me guess, let me guess, and that.
Oh, what a great booking, Sean.
杰森。嗨，杰森。杰森，接电话。杰森，是你母亲。首先，她是英国人。哦，好吧。但让我猜猜，让我猜猜，那个。哦，真是个棒极了的预约，肖恩。
Congratulations.
Guys, can I just,
Can I start by saying, I'm so excited to be on the gong show podcast,
all things you want to know about the new gong show.
And it is just, I mean, it's sweeping the country, both countries, Canada and U.S.
Aren't that taking fire?
It's unbelievable.
Are you just drinking?
祝贺你。伙计们，我能，我能先说一句吗，我很兴奋能来到这个“锣秀”播客，所有关于新“锣秀”你想知道的事。这简直是，我是说，它正在席卷全国，两个国家，加拿大和美国。难道不是火遍两岸吗？这太不可思议了。你是在喝酒吗？
Is that just medicine out of the bottle?
That's what it looks like.
That's a kombucha.
I know that because my wife drinks those.
But it does look like a tonic from...
Like old-time tonic.
Yeah, and I just, I drink it as a prophylactic.
Sure, yeah.
那瓶子里装的是药吗？看起来像那样。那是康普茶。我知道是因为我妻子喝那个。但它看起来确实像一种来自……老式补药的东西。对，我喝它只是把它当成一种预防药。当然，是的。
Will Ferrell, thank you so much for coming on our little show.
My pleasure.
And we're all obviously such gigantic fans of yours.
And one question, you know, you're one of the rare people in this business,
and I think I can speak on behalf of everybody that's, you know,
it's really hard to find people like you.
Hold on one second.
Will Ferrell's got a phone.
威尔·法瑞尔，非常感谢你来到我们的小节目。我的荣幸。显然我们都是你的超级粉丝。有一个问题，你知道的，你是这个行业中少有的人，我想我可以代表所有人说，你知道的，很难找到像你这样的人。等一下。威尔·法瑞尔有电话。
call.
Yes.
Tight five, everybody.
Okay, that's a large pepperoni, right?
Uh-oh.
Do you want to, do you want chicken fingers with that?
I thought he was ordering.
He's taking orders.
呼叫。好的，各位，五分钟速报。好的，那是一个大号意式辣香肠披萨，对吧？哦噢。你想，你想配鸡柳吗？我以为他在点餐。他在接单。
Okay.
Can I get the, oh, all right.
All right, Todd.
We'll be there in 35 minutes.
He asked for the address, and then he knew the guy, so we didn't need the address.
Hey, hey, keep your landlines, folks.
Keep your landlines.
好吧。我能要，哦，好吧。好吧。好吧，托德。我们35分钟后到。他问了地址，然后他认识那个人，所以我们不需要地址。嘿，嘿，大家保留好座机。保留好座机。
It is pretty strong.
When the banking system collapse, you're going to want to have a landlord.
What I was going to say, William, was Farrell, was I always wanted to know what is that one thing or that one event or that one person that made you want to get in the business and pursue comedy.
Barack Obama.
Correct.
But before that, before that.
Great answer.
Just like a week before that.
这确实挺带劲的。当银行体系崩塌时，你会庆幸自己有个房东。威廉，法瑞尔，我刚才想说的是，我一直想知道究竟是哪件事、哪场活动还是哪个人，让你想要进入这个行业并追求喜剧？巴拉克·奥巴马。正确。但在那之前，在那之前。好答案。就在那之前大约一个星期。
The one thing.
The one person?
Yeah, was there like a show or a person or an event or something in your family or?
Oh, Jesus.
This is supposed to be things you don't know.
Here come the waterworks.
Yeah.
And we are losing light.
那件事。那个人？对，当时是有什么节目、什么人、什么活动，还是你家里有什么事，或者是？哦，天哪。这本该是聊一些你们不知道的事。催泪弹要来了。对，我们在失去光线。
We're losing light.
I said I wouldn't cry.
You said you wouldn't try to get me to cry, Sean.
But right out of the gate.
Here's the real answer to your question.
Yeah.
I enjoyed being funny as a child, but I was actually diametrically opposed to going into entertainment
because I watched my father, the musician, go from job to job and be fired at the drop of a hat.
我们在失去光线。我说过我不会哭的。肖恩，你说过你不会试图弄哭我的。但一开场就这样。这是你问题的真正答案。对。我小时候喜欢搞笑，但我其实非常反感进入娱乐行业，因为我看着身为音乐家的父亲从一份工作跳到另一份工作，说被解雇就被解雇。
And I thought, who would want to do that?
I'm going to have a job where I carry a briefcase to work.
I can relate to that.
I had some of the same fears myself, yet I still went into this non-meritocracy.
and fickle sort of industry.
You went in early.
You were early.
You were early child.
我想，谁会想过这种生活？我要找一份带着公文包上班的工作。我对此很有共鸣。我自也有过一些同样的恐惧，但我还是进入了这个既不凭实力、又反复无常的行业。你入行很早。你很早就入行了。你很小就入行了。
Right, but you were young as well, but I mean, not a child,
but I mean, you still had an opportunity to take a different path,
yet you didn't.
You still, you couldn't resist the allure of the pancake makeup.
Yeah, so what about that, though?
The floor lights.
After seeing your dad.
Are there still floor lights?
对，但你当时也很年轻，我的意思是，虽然不是小孩子，但我的意思是，你仍然有机会选择一条不同的路，然而你没有。你仍然，你无法抗拒舞台妆的诱惑。对，那这个呢？舞台灯光。在看到你父亲之后。现在还有舞台灯光吗？
Yep.
There's scoop lights.
Scoop lights.
Yeah, yeah, scoop, scoop.
Yeah, scoop.
No, okay, listen, Will, but seeing your dad do that over and over again and not like, you know, travel, not hold down, you know, secure kind of jump.
So what, if that discouraged you, what encouraged you?
有啊。有聚光灯。聚光灯。对，对，聚光灯，聚光灯。对，聚光灯。对，聚光灯。不，好吧，听着，威尔，但是看到你父亲一次又一次地那样做，而且不喜欢，你知道的，四处奔波，无法保住一份，你知道的，稳定一点的工作。所以，如果那让你感到沮丧，是什么鼓励了你？
I just kind of slowly started incorporating the messing around with my friends, which I'm sure we all did.
Keep it clean.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, okay, you're right.
entertainment of my friend.
Ooh, that sounds weird.
Yeah.
The massage.
我只是开始慢慢地把和朋友们胡闹融入其中，我确信我们大家以前都这么干过。说正经的。好吧，对。对，好吧，你是对的。娱乐我的朋友。哦，听起来怪怪的。对。按摩。
No?
No.
Tickle giggle.
You know, we'd love to have a good gang tickle giggle.
That's it.
We got it.
We're back on.
不？不。咯吱咯吱笑。咯吱咯吱笑。你知道的，我们很乐意来一场痛快的群聚咯吱咯吱笑。就是这样。我们懂了。我们回来了。
No, I just had, high school was kind of the moment,
even though I wasn't like a theater kid or anything.
And I found myself writing.
what were essentially skits.
But was there like a comedy person that you were like,
God, I wish I could do what that guy does?
Who did you think was funny when you were a teenager?
I kind of the typical...
不，我只是觉得，高中可以说是那个转折点，尽管我不是什么戏剧特长生之类的人。我发现自己开始写东西了。基本上就是一些小品。但是有没有哪个喜剧演员让你觉得，天哪，我希望我能像那家伙一样搞笑？你当青少年的时候觉得谁好笑？我差不多就是那种典型……
Interesting that Will Arnett asks it once and gets a response.
The pipes.
Yeah, it's the pipes, exactly.
I just got down to it.
I didn't dress it up with a bunch of BS, Hayes.
I was a member of the Columbia House Record and Tape Club.
And one of the items...
Oh, you're being serious.
有意思的是，威尔·阿奈特问了一次就得到了回应。这嗓音。对，就是这嗓音，没错。我直奔主题。我没有用一堆废话来修饰，海斯。我是哥伦比亚唱片磁带俱乐部（Columbia House）的会员。其中一项……哦，你是认真的。
I'm being serious.
For $1 plus postage and handling,
which really comes out to about a buck 89,
that's where they get you.
I got to choose 13...
Still seething.
Well, it was supposed to be for a penny.
You've got 13 albums, and it's not a penny.
我是认真的。只要1美元加上邮费和处理费，实际算下来大约是1块89，这就是他们坑你的地方。我可以挑选13张……还在耿耿于怀。好吧，那本该是一分钱的。你拿到了13张专辑，结果根本不是一分钱。
It's a buck 89.
Okay?
It's the handling that's expensive.
Okay, man. We don't work there.
It's the postage and the shipping and handling.
Yeah.
Not to mention, if you get a...
You get one record a month.
是1块89。好吗？手续费才贵呢。得了，老兄。我们又不在那儿上班。那是邮费、运费和处理费。更不用说，如果你拿到一个……你每个月会收到一张唱片。
If you don't send it back within 14 days, you're charged for it.
Yeah.
Is that how you still use Netflix?
I'm doing it the original way.
Yeah, I never.
I still get the discs.
I'm not streaming it.
Will drives by Ted Serendos house and throws discs at his front door.
如果你不在14天内寄回去，你就要为它付费。对。你现在还是这样用Netflix的吗？我是用最原始的方式。对，我从来不。我还在拿碟片。我没有在流媒体上看。威尔开车经过泰德·萨兰多斯的房子，把碟片扔在前门。
Here's your fucking movies.
I'm done with these, Ted.
One of my, one of my, was the cast album of Saturday.
night lives. Okay, great. So you always aspired to
to be on the show that you were on? I guess quietly, yes. Quietly, I did.
But that's, so Will, so you wanted to...
That and, hold on, I'm not done.
Yeah, shut up, Arnett. I know.
这是你他妈的电影。我受够这些了，泰德。我的一个，我的一个，是《周六夜现场》的演员专辑。哦，太棒了。所以你一直渴望登上你后来加入的节目？我想悄悄地，是的。我悄悄地有。但那是，所以威尔，所以你想……还有，等等，我还没说完。对，闭嘴，阿奈特。我知道。
Fuck. Will, can I talk to you privately real quick? Yeah, yeah.
No, no, Arnett, sorry. Listen, yeah, listen, Arnett, when the guest is
responding to a question, especially one that you answer, for Christ's sake. No,
no, wait until there's silence, you guys.
Because silence follows a completion of the fucking answer.
Here we go.
Steve Martin.
操。威尔，我能跟你单独说句话吗？快点。对，对。不，不，阿奈特，抱歉。听着，对，听着，阿奈特，当嘉宾在回答问题时，尤其是你回答的那种问题，看在上帝的份上。不，不，等有了沉默再说，伙计们。因为沉默紧跟在那个他妈的回答结束之后。我们开始吧。史蒂夫·马丁。史蒂夫·马丁。
Yep.
And then I was also a tonight show weirdo.
I'd stay up and wait to see who the comedian was.
If there was a comedian on that night, I'd watch.
If there wasn't, I'd turn it off.
Wow.
So I was kind of, that's how I...
So those are the guys.
对。然后我还是一个《今夜秀》怪咖。我熬夜等着看当晚的喜剧演员是谁。如果那天晚上有喜剧演员，我就看。如果没有，我就关掉。哇。所以我差不多就是，我是这样……所以这就是那些人。
Steve Martin, also an idol of mine, too, comedy-wise.
I just thought so dry and brilliant.
But what was that moment?
So you grew up in Orange County, you go to USC, and then you go to Groundlings.
What is that gap between when you, I never knew this, like from when you finished USC to groundlings, what was that gap?
Like, how did you?
So I graduate USC with a degree in sports journalism.
Wow.
史蒂夫·马丁，也是我的偶像之一，在喜剧方面。我只是觉得他那么干瘪、那么才华横溢。但那个时刻是什么？所以你在奥兰治县长大，去上了南加州大学，然后去了“地面lings”剧团。从你，我以前从来不知道这一点，从你读完南加州大学到去“地面lings”剧团，那段空白期是什么样的？比如，你是怎么……所以我从南加州大学毕业，拿的是体育新闻学位。哇。
So in my mind's eye, I'm going to go work on ESPN.
You know, I'm going to be a sportscaster.
Oh, that would have been great.
I know, I blew it.
And, uh, missed it.
In fact, Craig Kilbourne brings that up to me every day.
Do you guys, you remember Craig Kilburn?
Sure do.
所以在我的脑海里，我要去ESPN工作。你知道的，我要成为一名体育播音员。哦，那本会很棒的。我知道，我搞砸了。而且，错过了。事实上，克雷格·基尔伯恩每天都拿这事来找我茬。你们，你们还记得克雷格·基尔伯恩吗？当然记得。
Do you have an ongoing friendship with Craig Kilbourne?
I haven't seen him in probably 15 years, no.
Well, he's on next.
He's coming on next.
Come on out, Craig.
You'll see him in the green room on your way off.
If you were quarantining with Craig Kilbourne, that would be it for me.
你和克雷格·基尔伯恩一直保持着友谊吗？我大概有15年没见他了，没有。哦，他下一期要来。他下一期要来。出来吧，克雷格。你走的时候在化妆室里就能看到他。出来吧，克雷格。如果你和克雷格·基尔伯恩一起隔离，那对我就够了。
Oh, wouldn't that be the greatest?
So you finish.
So, yeah, so I have this, I finish, and then I start doing my, I mean,
there wasn't really a job placement program coming out of college.
And so you kind of have to figure out a way.
I found like a local Orange County cable access news station I started working at.
And I was trying to put together a tape, which I wish we could cut to that now, that.
Oh, we'll find it.
哦，那难道不是最棒的事吗？所以你毕业了。所以，是的，所以我有了这个，我毕业了，然后我开始做我的，我是说，大学毕业后并没有真正的就业安置项目。所以你得自己想办法找出路。我找到了一家当地的奥兰治县有线电视新闻台，开始在那里工作。我当时在试着剪辑出一盘带子，我真希望我们现在能切到那个画面，那个……哦，我们会找到的。
In which, yeah, I did sort of do some field reporting and you would anchor the news.
You'd also work the camera.
You would do everything.
And there was a light bulb moment in that even though it was this small rinky dink local cable access,
they had legitimate press credentials to all the major sports teams in L.A.
And at that time, the Rams, the L.A. Rams football team were playing down at Anaheim Stadium.
And the editor of the show, which was actually a teacher of the class, it was actually run out of a junior college,
he said, hey, we need someone to go interview John Robinson, the head coach of the Rams.
其中，是的，我确实做了一些现场报道，你得当新闻主播。你还得操作摄像机。你什么都得干。有一个顿悟的时刻，那就是尽管这只是一个小型、破烂的当地有线电视，但他们拥有洛杉矶所有主要球队的合法记者证。当时，公羊队，也就是洛杉矶公羊队橄榄球队正在阿纳海姆体育场比赛。那个节目的剪辑师，其实也是那个班的老师，这个课实际上是由一所初级学院开设的，他说，嘿，我们需要有人去采访拉姆队的总教练约翰·罗宾逊。
at the stadium after this weekend's game.
And 40 hands shot up except for mine.
But you knew him from SC, yeah?
No, no, no.
I'd never met him, but the point was,
I'm surrounded by these hungry people
who were like, I need that interview on my reel.
And my first thought was like,
在周末的比赛结束后去体育场采访他。40只手齐刷刷地举了起来，除了我的。但你从南加州大学时就认识他，对吧？不，不，不。我从来没见过他，但重点是，我被周围这些如饥似渴的人包围着，他们说，我简历上需要那个采访。而我的第一反应是……
I'm going to have to check out a camera.
Parking.
I got to ask someone.
Yeah, parking.
I got to pay for it.
I got to ask one of my classmates
if they'll run sound for me.
Yeah.
我还得去借一台摄像机。停车。我还得问别人。对，停车。我还得付停车费。我还得问我哪个同班同学愿意帮我收音。对。
And you don't have a lot of money left over
from that subscription to all those.
From Columbia.
Yeah.
No, I'm in debt from Columbia House,
Records and tape.
Because he's in the middle of a major lawsuit
against California.
而且你买那些订阅杂志剩下的钱也不多了。从哥伦比亚。对。不，我因为哥伦比亚唱片磁带俱乐部欠了一屁股债。因为他正处于对加州的一场重大诉讼之中。
We are on the five-yard line, guys.
And please have me on next
when we finally come to terms.
But I'm giving all the money to charity.
But God, we're going to hammer them.
But I had no, I had no, I said, this is not a good sign.
I should be leaping out of my chair to go and actually get a legit interview with a head football coach from the NFL on my reel so that I can get hired at a, you know, station in Yuma, Arizona.
And I said, if I don't, I don't really have that drive, then this other thing that's kind of still gnawing away at me is, I don't.
伙计们，我们已经推进到五码线了。等我们最终达成协议时，请务必让我再来上节目。而且我会把所有的钱都捐给慈善机构。但天哪，我们要狠狠地打击他们。但我没有，我没有，我说，这不是个好兆头。我本该从椅子上跳起来，去争取一个合法的NFL球队主教练采访放到我的简历上，这样我才能在亚利桑那州尤马的一家……电台找到工作。我说，如果我没有，我没有那种动力，那么另一件一直在折磨我的事情是，我不……
I should really be looking into this comedy thing.
So that's when I signed up for my first class of the Groundlings.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm not trying to prod you into doing it.
How soon after that did you kind of braid the two things by working on your Harry Carey?
Oh, that was, yeah, that was kind of midway.
That was a couple years later during the baseball strike.
我真的应该好好考虑一下这个喜剧的事。所以这就是我报名参加第一堂“地面lings”表演课的时候。真的吗？对。我不是在催促你这么做。那在那之后多久，你通过创作哈里·卡瑞（Harry Carrey）把这两件事结合在了一起？哦，那是，是的，那大约是在中期。几年后的棒球罢工期间。
And just kills me.
Oh, that was a character you did at Groundlings?
Yeah, yeah, it was the baseball strike.
And I used to, I had a job, the art auction house.
that my then friend, now wife, Vivica, used to work at,
I was the appraisal coordinator at the auction house,
which was basically, I answered the phones and coordinated appraisals
and typed up appraisals.
这简直让我笑死。哦，那是你在“地面lings”时做的一个角色？对，对，那是棒球罢工期间。我以前，我有一份工作，在一家艺术拍卖行。我当时的朋、现在的妻子维维卡曾在那里工作，我是拍卖行的估价协调员，基本上就是我接电话、协调估价并打出估价报告。
Wow.
And was threatened to be fired on several occasions.
But I lived close enough home to drive home for lunch,
and I would turn the Cubs games on during the day.
And I had never heard of Harry Carrey,
And I was like, who is this guy?
Yeah, I grew up in Chicago, so he was part of our lives.
A fixture, right.
哇。而且好几次面临被解雇的威胁。但我家住得离公司够近，中午可以开车回家，白天我会打开小熊队的比赛听。我以前从没听说过哈里·卡瑞，我就想，这家伙是谁？对，我在芝加哥长大，所以他是我们生活的一部分。一个台柱子，对吧。
And so I'm just, I would be listening.
And the thing that struck me was listening to a game
and listening to this announcer say on syndicated national television,
If that ball's a strike, I'm a Chinaman.
And I, I live.
literally did like a spit take and was like, did he just say Chinaman?
And wait, wait, wait, this is like a guy who's paid to do this?
He's like, uh, and so I not, not, I just thought, no, this is, this has got to be a sketch somehow.
所以我只是，我一直在听。让我震惊的是，听着比赛，听着这个播音员在全国联合广播电视上说：如果那个球是个好球，我就是个中国佬。而我，我简直当场喷了出来，心想，他刚才是不是说了“中国佬”？等等，等等，等等，这是一个拿薪水干这行的人吗？他就像是，呃，所以我没有，没有，我只是想，不，这，这肯定是个某种小品。
And they, they, so I somehow, even though it was a Southern California audience, I wrote a sketch
where it was during the baseball strike. So Harry Carey didn't have games to announce and he would,
he had somehow gotten involved in a play reading and in a local theater.
And it was this melodramatic play.
And they were just sitting around, you know, let's take it from Act 1.
And it was, you know, Perry had lines like, God damn it, Carol.
Why don't you ever look at me when we make love?
And I, I, I, and by.
然后他们，他们，所以我不知怎么地，尽管那是南加州的观众，我写了一个小品，背景是棒球罢工期间。所以哈里·卡瑞没有比赛可播，他不知怎么地参与了一部戏剧的排练，在一家当地剧院里。那是一部很闹剧的戏剧。他们只是坐在那儿，你知道的，我们从第一幕开始。然后，你知道的，哈里的台词是这样的：该死的，卡罗尔。为什么我们做爱的时候你从来不看着我？而我，我，我，到……
By the end of the sketch, the audience was like doubling over and laughter,
even though they had no idea that Harry Carey was a real person.
Oh, right.
This is something that's transcending, you know.
Yeah.
By the way, never knowing that, of course, you do the Harry Carrey character so many times,
but the idea of him doing something, it was always in the baseball context,
but seeing him doing something that's completely out of.
到小品结束时，观众们笑得前仰后合，尽管他们完全不知道哈里·卡瑞是个真人。哦，对。这是某种超越了……你知道的。顺便说一句，从来不知道，当然，你扮演哈里·卡瑞这个角色很多次了，但脑海中他做某事的想法，虽然总是在棒球的语境下，但看到他做完全不着边际的事情……
Oh, yeah.
And we had all these other actors.
We had a really good troop, and everyone was just playing it perfectly straight.
And, like, this one actress, Maggie Barrett, was literally getting herself to cry while she read it.
And it was just, you're like, your tears made nothing to me.
This marriage has been broken since the day we crossed the altar.
Always kind of drunk, right?
Yeah.
哦，对。我们还有其他所有演员。我们有一个非常棒的剧团，每个人都演得极其正经。而且，像其中一个女演员玛吉·巴雷特，她在读台词时真的让自己哭了。这就好像，你的眼泪对我来说毫无意义。自从我们走过圣坛的那天起，这段婚姻就破碎了。总是有点醉醺醺的，对吧？对。
Yeah, and then.
And quaking a little.
And then my friend Roy was the director, like, okay, let's stop there.
I don't know if I'm feeling, you know, just giving the crochet acting notes and like, Harry, I really want to feel it from you this time.
And you're speaking to no one but Carol right now in the scene.
Okay, let's take it again.
And just the starting and stopping of that.
Did you do Harry when you did your S&L audition?
对，然后。而且还有点发抖。然后我的朋友罗伊作为导演，就说，好吧，我们到那儿停一下。我不知道我有没有感觉到，你知道的，只是给出钩针编织般的表演指导，就像是，哈里，这次我真的想从你身上感受到那种感觉。在这场戏里，你除了卡罗尔谁也不对视。好吧，我们再来一次。就是那种开始又停下的过程。你在参加《周六夜现场》试镜时演过哈里吗？
I did, which was, in fact, I tried to do an augmented version of that.
And it was so surreal because, you know, you're just in a void.
You're on, you're in 8H in the studio there.
God, you must have been so nervous.
I would have just a mess.
I just remember listening, waiting in the way.
So you guys all know that set up there,
waiting by the page desk outside the doors of the studio.
演过，事实上，我试着表演了一个那个角色的增强版。这太超现实了，因为，你知道的，你就像在一个虚无的空间里。你在那里，在8H演播室里。天哪，你当时一定紧张极了。我要是去的话肯定一团糟。我只记得在听，在通道里等待。所以你们都知道那个布景，在演播室大门外的传达台旁等待。
And hearing the person ahead of you go through their audition while you're on deck.
And just looking at all the famous pictures of everyone who had just hosted.
And being in the spot,
and the place that you dreamed of being and now you're there.
And then walking out to a studio that's pitch black
except for a spotlight and a camera and a boom operator
and Lauren sitting in the shadows
and then you just have to do comedy.
听着排在你前面的人在候场时进行他们的试镜。看着墙上刚刚主持过节目的所有名人的照片。身处这个你曾梦想过的地方，而现在你就在这里。然后走进一个除了聚光灯、摄像机、挑杆收音员和坐在阴影里的洛恩之外一片漆黑的演播室，然后你必须开始搞笑。
Or standing.
And avoid, possibly.
So yeah, that was very surreal.
I tried doing it.
I don't know.
Will, Farrell, I also want to know,
like, have you ever desired to do anything?
I know you wanted to be a sports?
或者站着。可能也是一片虚无。所以，是的，那非常超现实。我试着演了。我不知道。威尔·法瑞尔，我还想知道，比如，你曾经渴望做过什么吗？我知道你想成为一名体育……
announcer, right, or sportscaster.
But if you weren't doing the thing that you're doing,
not quarantining, but in entertainment business,
what would you be doing?
If you had to pick a blue-collar job,
you had to pick, what would it be?
Oh, blue-call.
Because I was going to say, I've always wanted to do finance.
播音员，对吧，或是体育解说员。但如果你干的不是现在这行，不是隔离，而是在娱乐行业之外，你会做什么？如果你必须选择一份蓝领工作，你必须选，会是什么？哦，蓝领。因为我本来想说，我一直想做金融。
It seems so interesting to you.
I love finance.
I love figuring out like a second more.
you know, I can't even do the bit because I don't even know the terms.
Right, refi.
Refi low.
Will comes alive.
When you mentioned private equity, it's like.
对你来说这似乎太有趣了。我喜欢金融。我喜欢弄明白像多一秒……你知道的，我甚至连这个梗都演不出来了，因为我连术语都不知道。对，再融资。低利率再融资。威尔复活了。当你提到私募股权时，就像是……
What?
Who's that?
Are you?
Subprime?
Is that still a thing?
I actually could be a, I could actually be a post person, to be quite honest.
To deliver the mail.
Because I like, like the idea of a route.
什么？那是谁？你是吗？次贷？那现在还是个东西吗？老实说，我其实可以当个，我其实可以当个邮递员。去送信。因为我喜欢，比如一条固定路线的概念。
and you get to, you know, have some contact with people and the idea of finishing a task every day.
Would you be on foot armed with the dog spray or would you be in the buggy?
I would go foot with the trolley.
I'd push the trolley.
Nice.
Yeah.
Those are sneaky tricky.
然后你可以，你知道的，和人们有一些接触，而且每天都有完成一项任务的感觉。你会步行拿着防狗喷雾，还是开着邮政小车？我会步行推着手推车。我推手推车。不错。是的。不错。那些东西挺阴险棘手的。
Those three wheels thing, they will go over on you.
I'm sure they, yeah, in a high wind or.
Yeah.
Or if you don't take the letters out, you don't go in a clockwise or counterclockwise rotation.
If you take too many out of the left side, it's going to tip over on the right and vice versa.
Did you used to do it?
Hey, how often did you look out the window masturbating at the postman?
A lot or a little?
那三个轮子的东西，它们会翻倒的。我敢肯定它们会，是的，在强风中或者。是的。或者如果你不把信件拿出来，你不按顺时针或逆时针方向转圈。如果你从左边拿走太多信，它就会向右倾斜翻倒，反之亦然。你以前干过吗？嘿，你有多经常看着窗外对着邮递员手淫？经常还是偶尔？
Only in the summer months when they wear the shorts.
Look at that card.
There's David.
David are postman's here.
Yeah.
David is going to topple.
David's going to topple.
只有在他们穿短裤的夏天。看那张卡片。那是大卫。那是大卫，大卫邮递员来了。对。大卫要摔倒了。大卫要摔倒了。
I'll get the mail.
Hey, guys, David's here.
Yes, so what?
Wait.
Cut to the reverses.
nobody's there.
Nobody's there.
He's alone.
我去拿信。嘿，伙计们，大卫来了。对，那又怎样？等等。切到反打镜头。没人。没人。他孤身一人。
Hey, Bateman, quick question.
Because you did, we mentioned before you grew up in showbiz.
We all know that.
We've seen the great things and people who are listening can right now Google up like Little House in the Prairie and see cute little Jason Bateman.
Yeah.
Did you ever have a real, did you ever have like an outside show business job?
Have you ever had like a?
I didn't.
嘿，贝特曼，问个快问题。因为你做过，我们之前提到过你是在娱乐圈长大的。我们都知道这一点。我们看过那些精彩的作品，现在正在听节目的观众可以上谷歌搜一下《草原小屋》，看看可爱的小杰森·贝特曼。对。你有没有过真正的，你有没有过任何娱乐圈之外的工作？你有没有做过像……我没有。
And I genuinely hate that.
I'd love to have had a paper route similar to.
Dave's route with his three-wheeler.
But you were working all the time as a kid.
I started at 10, yeah.
So there was no chance to.
But I've always legitimately fantasized about waiting tables or bartending.
There's something about working for a tip, which is sort of like the same thing as I want them to like me.
我真的挺讨厌这样的。我真希望能有一条像……戴夫那种推着三轮车的路线一样的送报路线。但你小时候一直在工作。我10岁就开始了，对。所以没有机会去……但我一直真正地幻想过端盘子或调酒。为小费工作有种奇妙的感觉，这就有点像“我希望他们喜欢我”。
I want this table.
Might need something different than that table.
Just sort of like being able to morph into whatever they need me to be.
I have, I will say this.
All my quote unquote civilian jobs, I've been pretty terrible.
at. So.
Because you didn't like authority or you were just disinterested?
No, like slow. Yeah, just like slow on the uptake. I had a lot of patient managers and supervisors
我想要这张桌子。可能需要和那张桌子做点不同的事。就是那种能够变成他们需要的任何人的能力。我得这么说。我所有所谓的平民工作，我都做得相当糟糕。
who did you have a lot of jobs, like, do you have weird jobs in high school that you did?
I never, I was doing sports all the time. So I, but I had, you know, I had like the, I worked as a
bank teller. I was a valet parker of cars.
And, uh, how are you taking direction?
Well, you know, bank teller, you know, there's certain protocols and procedures you have to follow and this and that.
It just took me a while.
I mean, the fact that I was handling numbers and money was, it just, I was like.
Euphoric.
因为你不喜欢权威，还是单纯不感兴趣？不，比如反应慢。对，就是反应比较迟钝。我有很多有耐心的经理和主管，你做过很多工作吗？比如，你在高中时做过什么奇怪的工作吗？我从来没有，我一直在搞体育。所以我，但我有，你知道的，我有类似，我在银行当过出纳。我当过代客泊车员。还有，你是怎么接受指导的？嗯，你知道的，银行出纳，你知道的，有一些必须遵循的特定协议和程序，诸如此类。我只是花了点时间。我的意思是，我经手数字和金钱的事实，就让我感到……欣喜若狂。
What am I doing here?
The finance lost.
I mean, that led to my love to finance.
But I once had a regular customer stop me in the middle of a transaction and say, can you call your manager over?
And I said, sure.
and I brought her over and he's and in front of me he said this guy is your worst teller okay
and I just want you to know this and he did in a very calm way and he was like look look at him right now
he's sweating and I literally was I was sweating he's like he's terrible he takes forever he um and and
我在这里干什么？金融失落。我的意思是，那引发了我对金融的热爱。但我曾有一个老客户在交易中途叫住我，说：你能把你经理叫过来吗？我说：当然。然后我把她叫了过来，当着我的面他说：这家伙是你手下最差的出纳，好吧。我只是想让你知道这一点。他用一种非常平静的方式说了出来，他说：看，看他现在，他在出汗。而我确实在出汗。他说：他太糟糕了，他慢得要死，他……
the manager to her defense was like please that's that's not true and I was like no he's kind of
right and uh and I just want you know like I hate when I have to go to his Wednesday
And then he just walked away.
And she was like, I'm sorry about that.
I was like, you know what?
I can't really argue with him.
There's a, I'm not that great to tell her.
This was counting bills, counting out cash or?
为了维护她自己，经理说：请别这样，那不是真的。而我说：不，他说的有点道理。而且，你知道的，就像，我讨厌周三不得不去他那儿。然后他就走开了。她就说：真不好意思。我说：你知道吗？我真的没法反驳他。作为出纳我确实不太行。这是在点钞票，清点现金还是？
You know, everything, cashing a chat.
Yeah, do it all.
So.
That guy did you a favor in the long run, right?
In a lot of ways, sounds like you need to pen someone a letter.
Well, every time I go, every time I put the pancake makeup on,
and I picture that guy.
And I say, who's laughing now?
你知道的，什么都干，兑现支票。对，全干。所以。从长远来看，那家伙帮了你一个大忙，对吧？从很多方面来看，听起来你得给某人写封信。嗯，每次我去，每次我化上舞台妆，我就会想起那个家伙。然后我说：到底谁才是笑到最后的那个？
So you still do all your own makeup?
I insist on it.
It's crazy.
Well, there's allergies.
Especially in the, you know, post-COVID-19 world we're all about to step into.
I will definitely be doing all my own makeup.
So, Will Ferrell, you are one of the funniest people on the planet,
if not the funniest person on the planet.
所以你现在还是自己化所有的妆？我坚持要自己化。这太疯狂了。嗯，因为有过敏反应。特别是在我们即将迈入的这个后新冠疫情世界里。我绝对会自己化所有的妆。所以，威尔·法瑞尔，你是这个星球上最搞笑的人之一，如果不是最搞笑的人的话。
And everybody kind of, do you get sick of like, because now you're a parent and you have to show up to like school things and parent things for your kids?
Do people expect that from you all the time?
And what is your reaction?
There is a certain level of underwhelment.
Is that a word?
Yes.
Yeah.
It is now.
每个人都，比如，你是不是厌倦了，因为现在你是一个父母，你得去参加诸如学校活动和孩子的家长会之类的事情？人们是不是一直对你抱有那种期望？你的反应是什么？有一种程度的“大失所望”。这是一个词吗？是的。是的。现在是了。
I can tell there are a lot of let down people continually.
But Will, I will say this, you know, Will, I'd have a lot of.
you remember this a couple years ago.
Maybe last year we were having dinner.
Yeah.
I was having dinner with Richter and Pete Giles.
And you and Viv came in from a school event.
Yeah.
我能看出有很多人不断感到失望。但威尔，我得这么说，你知道，威尔，我有过很多。你还记得几年前这事吗？也许是去年我们在一起吃晚饭。对。我和里克特还有皮特·吉尔斯在吃晚饭。你和维维从一个学校活动过来。对。
And with a couple other parents.
And Will was wearing his name tag.
And they're all wearing name tags.
And Will says, hello, my name is Will on the thing, which is great.
And that's such a testament to what a great guy you are.
And it's like, yeah, man, I'm not here.
I'm just here because my kids are at school here.
And I'm interested in my kids and their lives and their
还有其他几位家长。威尔当时戴着他的名牌。他们都戴着名牌。威尔说：你好，我叫威尔，在那上面，这太棒了。这充分证明了你是一个多么好的人。这就好像，是啊，老兄，我不是来这儿的。我来这儿只是因为我的孩子在这儿上学。我对我的孩子和他们的生活感兴趣，还有他们的……
It's cool.
But I'm sure you guys face the same thing.
I find more that there are some parents who literally won't say hi because they go so far the
other way.
Yeah.
I don't want to bother him.
So then you're like, hey, how you doing?
And they walk right by.
这很酷。但我确信你们也面临着同样的情况。我更多地发现，有些家长甚至不打招呼，因为他们刻意走向了另一个极端。对。我不想打扰他。所以你就会说：嘿，你好吗？然后他们直接从旁边走了过去。
And they're like, gosh, what did I say something wrong?
Yeah.
And then do you feel on the opposite of that, do you feel that you have to sometimes lead with
sort of a vibe that is less than sort of friends?
or less than sort of solicitous of conversation because you're afraid that if you seem too friendly,
they're really going to lean in?
And like, how do you kind of...
他们就像是，天哪，我是不是说错什么了？对。对。然后你在与此相反的情况时，你是否觉得你有时必须表现出一种不太像朋友的气场？或者不太主动去交谈的气场，因为你担心如果你显得太友好，他们就会真的顺杆往上爬？就像你是如何……
No, I would say that, I would say at least in the school setting, most everyone is, is relatively normal.
I would say that posture, that's my game face for when I'm on a commercial flight.
Right.
Just, just sour, don't come near me.
I will rip your head off.
I will not hear.
Here, not here for fun and game.
Let's get to flying.
不，我会这么说，我会说至少在学校里，几乎每个人都是，相对正常的。我会说，那种姿态，那是我坐商业航班时的标准表情。对。就是，阴沉着脸，别靠近我。我会把你的头撕下来。我不会听。这里，这里可不是来玩乐的。我们要飞啦。
Eye mask and headphones.
Will, is there anything that you haven't done that you want to do,
either a role that you want to play or?
Nope.
Talk to you later.
Totally satisfied.
How do I turn this camera off?
How do I get out of it?
眼罩和耳机。威尔，有什么事是你还没做但你想做的，无论是你想演的角色还是？没了。回头见。完全满足。我怎么关掉这个摄像头？我怎么退出去？
How do I?
I did it.
No, there isn't because everybody thinks you can do anything.
I don't know.
But how do you, how do you, you can't give that answer without sounding like a jackass.
Right.
Yeah, what would you, what would you do if like, let's say, let's say Ridley Scott came to you and he wanted to do King Lear.
我怎么？我做到了。我怎么……不，没有，因为每个人都觉得你能做到任何事。我不知道。但你如何，你如何，你不能给出这样的答案而听起来像个混蛋。对。是的，你会怎么做，如果，比方说，比方说雷德利·斯科特来找你，他想拍《李尔王》。
And he just thought he sees something in you that would just be like an incredibly, it's off brand and studios excited and all of those terms and all of that stuff.
And the money's just like, like, you've never.
never, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Does your douche meter go off and say, even though you could do it, do you feel like the audience
will never accept it?
Yeah, I think that would be a, that would be a tough one to try to convince yourself that
you could pull that one off.
Having said that, you have, you have, you have, you have, King Lear.
他觉得他在你身上看到了某种特质，会觉得这简直太……不符合你的常规形象了，制片厂也很兴奋，所有这些术语和那些事情。片酬就像是，比如，你从来没见过的，等等，等等，等等。你的混蛋雷达会响起，然后说，尽管你能演，但你觉得观众永远不会接受吗？对，我想那会是一个艰难的抉择，很难说服自己你能演好那个角色。话虽如此，你已经，你已经，你已经，你已经，李尔王。
Are you about to, no.
Jason, are you direct, are you doing it?
No, but you have, but what about what?
And all sincerity, I think you've taken what you do and you've pushed it into so many realistic, dramatic, melancholy things that truly nobody else could do, just like no one else could do what you do in comedy.
I really think it's admirable how you are so aware of how you come across, what sort of your goalposts are and what you're asking the audience to accept you as, I think that's a lot of discipline.
I appreciate that.
But, yeah, I mean, it's fun to do that other stuff.
but there are times where I am always on those sets of more serious things going,
你是不是要，不。杰森，你在指挥，你在拍吗？没有，但你已经，但是什么呢？说句心里话，我觉得你把你做的事拿来，把它推向了那么多现实的、戏剧性的、忧郁的事情，真的没有人能像你一样做到，就像没有人能像你在喜剧中做得那么好一样。我真的觉得很令人钦佩，你对自己给人的印象有着多么清晰的认识，你的目标是什么，你要求观众接受你扮演什么角色，我觉得这需要很多纪律。我很感激。但，是的，我的意思是，演那些别的东西很有趣。但有时我在拍摄那些更严肃的片场时会想，
this is very hard.
And this is hard to not look like you're trying to be the actor who everyone needs to take serious.
So it's a drama face.
Yeah, it's so tough.
Which is so funny because doing what you do, specifically what you do will,
is so hard.
And when I say not many people,
like, nobody could do it.
这太难了。而且要看起来不像是那种“每个人都得严肃对待的演员”这很难。所以这就是一张正剧脸。对，太难了。这太有趣了，因为做你做的事，特别是你做的事，威尔，太难了。当我说没多少人时，就像，没有人能做到。
And it's so...
Working out, you mean?
Yeah, the way I work out?
Well, just lats, the way you do arms and legs.
Yeah.
Nobody does legs like you.
And you've always said that.
And thanks for the posts.
而且这太……你是说健身吗？对，我健身的方式？嗯，就是背阔肌，你练手臂和腿的方式。对。没有人能像你那样练腿。你一直这么说。谢谢你的帖子。
You always post them, too.
Not a lot of people know that we'll train Reggie Bush
when he came through as C.
I'm a fairly modest person.
I think you guys, I think that comes across here.
but I will not hold back.
No one does legs the way I do, you know?
I mean,
你总是发那些。没多少人知道我们曾训练雷吉·布什当他来到SC时。我是个相当谦逊的人。我想你们俩，我觉得这在节目里表现得很明显。但我不会隐瞒。没有人能像我那样练腿，你知道吗？我是说，
Leg day's a holiday in the Farrell household.
Leg day is, yeah, it's just...
Now, here's the other thing, Will Ferrell.
You know, you're also known not only as the funniest person in the world,
but one of the kindest people.
Everybody in this business always just raves about what a great human being you are.
That's the hard part.
I can't attest to that because you are.
在法瑞尔家里，练腿日就是个节日。练腿日是，是的，这只是……现在，还有一件事，威尔·法瑞尔。你知道，你不仅作为世界上最搞笑的人而闻名，而且还是最善良的人之一。这个行业的每个人总是对你是一个多么棒的人赞不绝口。这才是最难的部分。我无法证明这一点，因为你确实是。
you for. That's the part they pay you for. Very, very sweet. But so that said, I think the thing I
always wanted to know, what really pisses you off? Yeah, here we go. This is where we start the
interview. He's all kombuched up. Now, do you mean? Oh, I'm full of. No, we just want names. We just
want names. Yeah. When's the last time you just screamed your head off and let somebody had it?
Yeah, because I can't picture you angry. No, I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't,
I'm trying to think of the last.
I mean, I have screamed before.
I have screamed in a professional manner.
为了这个付钱给你。非常，非常甜美。但话虽如此，我一直想知道的是，什么真正惹恼了你？对，开始咯。我们这就开始采访了。他已经喝了一肚子康普茶了。现在，你是说？哦，我满肚子的……不，我们只要名字。我们只要名字。对。上一次你气急败坏、把某人骂得狗血淋头是什么时候？对，因为我无法想象你生气的样子。不，我不会，我不会，我不会，我不会，我在想上一次。我的意思是，我以前吼过。我曾以一种专业的方式吼过。
Or like in life, or like at home,
or like in people and human beings, what pisses you off?
Yeah, home, it's, you know, the typical frustrations you have with your children.
And for some reason, I'm always checking myself because I'm holding them to some standard that I don't think I was held to.
Like, I was, I was, I mean, I did well in school.
but I still had, you know, my room was a mess,
and I never emptied the dishwasher.
But for some reason, I'm just like, you guys, it's not that hard.
或者在生活中，或者在家里，或者对人、对人类，什么会惹恼你？对，在家里，是，你知道的，你对孩子感到的那种典型的沮丧。不知为什么，我总是在克制自己，因为我用一种连我自己当年可能都没达到标准去要求他们。比如，我，我，我的意思是，我学习很好。但我还是有，你知道的，我的房间一团糟，我从来不倒洗碗机。但不知为什么，我就是觉得，你们这群人，这没那么难。
We're asking you to empty the trash.
See, if I was your child, I would laugh at that.
And put the liner back in.
Put the liner back in.
Reline the trash can.
You're not done.
It's a two-step process.
Right.
我们只是要求你倒一下垃圾。看，如果我是你的孩子，我会嘲笑这个。然后把垃圾袋装回去。把垃圾袋装回去。给垃圾桶重新套上袋子。你还没完呢。这是一个两步的过程。对。
Yeah.
But that, for some reason, that, I get crazy.
And then I'm like, who is this person?
Yeah.
But I was going to say about holding them to that standard.
You know, during these weird times, we had the other day, Archie, or 11-year-old was on his Zoom class.
Yeah.
And it turned out he was, he had his camera off and on the side.
对。但不知为什么，那，我会抓狂。然后我就想，这人是谁？对。但我本来想说的是用那个标准去要求他们。你知道，在这个奇怪的时期，我们有天，阿尔奇，我们11岁的孩子在上他的Zoom课。对。结果发现他，他关了摄像头，然后在旁边。
He was on his iPad playing a video game.
So I said to Amy, I said to my ex, I was like, I was like, what are we, he's on the thing and blah, blah, blah.
And as I was saying to her, like, he's on the Zoom class, but he's on pause,
and he's playing a video game beat, beat, beat.
I was looking at her and I go, which I probably would have done if given the chance
and you probably would have too.
And she's like, yeah, I totally would.
I know.
他在用iPad玩电子游戏。所以我跟艾米说，我对我前妻说，我当时就说，我当时说，我们到底是什，他在弄那个，巴拉巴拉巴拉。当我对她说的时候，就像，他在上Zoom课，但他按了暂停，在打电子游戏，笃，笃，笃。我看着她，然后我说，如果我有机会我可能也会这么做，你大概也会。她说，对，我绝对会。我知道。
Yeah, exactly.
It was crazy.
I don't, I don't know why.
Yeah, I don't know why I go there.
But can I, I have one other thing.
I don't, in a work experience, kind of bugaboo.
Yeah.
I don't love the unit publicist experience on a set.
对，没错。太疯狂了。我，我不知道为什么。对，我不知道为什么我会那样。不过我可以，我还有另一件事。我不，在工作经历中，有点像个心病。对。我不喜欢片场的联合公关经历。
Right.
And for those listeners who are wondering,
there's a lot of times on a production,
there's a publicist assigned from the studio and this and that.
And they're always playing the game of like,
so-and-so's willing to do it if you are.
Right.
Guilting you.
对。对于那些好奇的听众，在制作过程中经常会有来自制片厂的公关被指派来负责这这那那。他们总是在玩那种游戏，比如，只要你肯，某某就愿意配合。对。用这个来让你内疚。
Yeah.
And they do these wide circles, right?
They just do little drive-bys every once in a while to gauge
whether you're in a good mood or a bad mood to just want to kind of run something
buy you.
And I'm always,
I'm always amazed at
对。对。而且他们总是绕着大圈子，对吧？他们每隔一段时间就会来进行一次小小的突击，来试探你今天是心情好还是心情不好，好顺便跟你商量点事。而我总是，我总是对……感到惊讶
we want to have 20 journalists
visit the set
and do a three-hour interview
while you guys are filming.
And I'm always like, but wait,
isn't the movie the first priority?
And I'm always, I'm always like,
absolutely, if we have time.
我们想让20名记者来片场参观，在你们拍摄期间进行三个小时的采访。而我总是觉得，等等，难道电影不是第一位的吗？而我总是会说，当然可以，如果我们有时间的话。
Okay, but when do you think will be a good time?
You'll have to check with the first
AD. Okay, but is there a window? I have no idea. So you're up for it? Yes, if we have time.
Okay. Great. So you've signed off. If we have time. Right. And then I love those days when there's
no time. You go, I'm sorry. There was no time. Will, what was the thing I remember you were
telling me once about? It kind of felt like the same thing. Somebody said to you, hey, we're going to do a
golf tournament. Tiger Woods is going to come if you're in. And like you felt like,
And then somebody had told Tiger that you were going to play.
好的，那您觉得什么时候比较有空？你得去问一下第一副导演。好吧，那有没有一个空档？我完全不知道。所以你答应了？对，如果我们有时间的话。好的。太好了。所以你同意了。如果我们有时间的话。对。然后我最喜欢那些根本没空的日子。你会说，很抱歉。完全没空。威尔，我还记得你以前跟我说过一件事，关于什么的？感觉有点像同一回事。有人对你，嘿，我们要办一场高尔夫锦标赛。如果你参加的话，泰格·伍兹也会来。就像你觉得，然后有人告诉老虎说你要去打球。
And it was like...
Yes.
Somehow my dad became a middleman.
My dad somehow became a middleman.
He was asking me, he had some friend of his down in Newport Beach who came to listen to him play music was like, hey, so he's talked to Tiger Woods.
And Tiger Woods is in for it.
if you and Tiger Woods play golf together,
感觉就像……是的。是的。不知怎么地，我爸爸成了中间人。我爸爸不知怎么地成了中间人。他问我，他在纽波特海滩有个朋友来听他弹音乐，就说，嘿，所以他跟泰格·伍兹聊过了。而泰格·伍兹也同意了，如果你和泰格·伍兹一起打高尔夫的话，
and they'll raise a bunch of money for charity for another two-sum,
so you're a four-sum together in these two, whoever, you know,
it goes to the highest bidder to play golf with Will Ferrell and Tiger Woods,
and that he's already reached out to Tiger, and it's good to go.
And I was like, well, Dad, who is this friend again?
And how well do you know him?
And he seems like a good guy.
And I go, well, you know, a lot of times they'll ask one,
他们会为慈善机构筹集一笔资金，组成一个四人组，你们这两组，不管是谁，你知道的，出价最高的人可以和威尔·费瑞尔以及泰格·伍兹一起打高尔夫，而且他已经联系过老虎了，一切都没问题。我说，爸，这朋友又是谁啊？你对他有多了解？他看起来是个好人。我说，好吧，你知道，很多时候他们会先问一方，
party before they asked the other.
And so maybe I'll check, let me do some research.
And for some way, I had some way to check to see if the Tiger Camp had ever heard
of this special charity golf.
Dr. Miller got involved.
Exactly.
And it turns out, of course, Tiger, I said, Dad, guess what?
Your buddy, Tiger Woods apparently, his team has never heard anything of this.
然后再问另一方。所以也许我会去查证一下，让我做点调查。不知怎么地，我有办法查证老虎的团队是否听说过这个特殊的慈善高尔夫球赛。米勒医生介入了。没错。结果当然是，老虎，我说，爸，你猜怎么着？你的好朋友泰格·伍兹，他的团队显然从来没听说过这事。
and your friend's lying to.
And he was like, how, how could that be?
And I said, I know.
That's the way the world sometimes works.
What kind of music does he play?
He's like an old-time rock and roll.
Really?
Yeah.
而你朋友在撒谎。他当时就说，怎么，怎么会这样？我说，我知道。世界有时就是这样运转的。他玩的是什么音乐？他说是一种老式摇滚乐。真的吗？对。
Guitarist?
No, he's piano, sax.
Hammond B-3 organ.
Wow.
Yeah.
Let's hear for the Hammond B3.
That's amazing.
吉他手？不，他是钢琴，萨克斯。哈蒙B-3风琴。哇。哇。对。为哈蒙B3风琴欢呼吧。太棒了。
But yeah, that was my Tiger Woods story.
I just, I always loved that idea, though.
I've thought about that so many times, the idea of like,
when they go like, hey, we want you to do this thing and so-and-so and so-and-so are doing it.
And I always think back to that story of like, and then I'll go,
well, why don't you make sure that so-and-so and so-and-so?
That's how I found myself on an island with Marie Osmond and Kurt Cameron, you know.
Oh, boy.
不过对，那是我的泰格·伍兹故事。不过我一直很喜欢那个主意。我想过好多次那个主意，当他们说，嘿，我们想让你做这件事，某某和某某都在做。我总是回想起那个故事，然后我会说，嗯，你为什么不确保某某和某某……这就是为什么我发现自己和玛丽·奥斯蒙德以及库尔特·卡梅伦孤零零地呆在一个岛上，你知道的。噢，天哪。
I got asked to play in another chair.
golf tournament by a friend assuming that I was going to play with the person I know.
Right.
Only to show up and be placed with four strangers.
And these guys were like in it to win it.
They're like, hey, hope you're pretty good.
Did you end up playing?
Yeah, I had to play this entire 18 holes with these four guys.
我应朋友之邀去参加另一个慈善高尔夫锦标赛，以为我会和我认识的人一组。对。结果到场后却被分给了四个陌生人。这些人是来真的。他们就像，嘿，希望你打得挺好。你最后打了吗？对，我不得不和这四个家伙打完全部18洞。
And they wanted to show you how good they were, right?
A hundred percent.
They were like, we hope you're good because we win this thing every year.
And you better be funny.
And you're, well, and it was early S&L days,
so they kind of had heard of me, maybe not.
They were like, is that show still on the air?
I don't even know people watched it.
他们想向你展示他们有多厉害，对吧？百分之百。他们就像，我们希望你打得好，因为我们每年都赢得这比赛。而且你最好幽默点。而且你，好吧，当时还是周六夜现场的早期，所以他们可能听说过我，也可能没听说过。他们就像，那个节目还在播吗？我都不知道有人看它。
Sweet.
He sounds sweet.
And then I literally, we were supposed to be a banquet afterwards.
And I said, guys, I'm going to put my clubs in my car,
and I'll meet you back inside.
Just drove home.
And did we win?
Yes, we won.
真贴心。他听起来真贴心。然后我真的，我们本该在赛后参加一个宴会的。我说，伙计们，我要把球杆放进车里，然后我在里面跟你们汇合。直接开车回家了。我们赢了吗？是的，我们赢了。
Even despite.
Did you really?
You didn't stick around for the trophy.
I didn't stick around.
That's strong.
Yeah.
So as we say goodbye to you in this pandemic day, what do you do the rest of the day?
Let's see.
尽管如此。真的吗？你没留下来拿奖杯。我没留下来。真有性格。对。所以在这个大流行的日子里，当我们向你道别时，你剩下的时间打算做什么？让我想想。
It's three in the afternoon.
I'm going to go, I might go walk our dogs, peanut and Cosmo, right?
So that's with a mask?
They'll be with a mask.
I'm going to do a sweep through the house to find where all the devices have been hidden
because these kids are liars and thieves.
So I'll do a sweep.
And then we'll start talking about, we start talking about what we're making for dinner at around noon every day.
现在是下午三点。我要去，我可能会去遛我们的狗，花生和科斯莫，对吧？所以要戴着口罩吗？它们会戴着口罩。我要把房子扫荡一遍，找出所有被藏起来的电子设备，因为这些孩子又撒谎又当小偷。所以我要搜查一遍。然后我们会开始讨论，每天中午左右开始讨论我们晚餐要做什么。
So we'll have to strike.
You've got to build a day around that.
And then it's sleep by eight.
Yeah.
Jason, have you done, or Will or Sean?
Well, not to your kids, but maybe to Scotty.
Have you ever done a thing where you go?
You still had it with the devices.
所以我们得开始。你得围绕这个来安排一天的生活。然后八点睡觉。对。杰森，你做过吗，或者威尔或肖恩？好吧，不是对你们的孩子，对斯科蒂也行。你有没有做过这样的事？你对电子设备还是这样。
I've threatened during this pandemic minimum 100 times to throw the devices in the pool.
Yes.
I said this iPad is going in the bottom of the pool if I see it on one more time.
Yeah.
Yeah, but then you quickly realize all that means is more work for you.
True.
I did throw my 13-year-old Matisse's phone out the window.
在这场大流行期间，我威胁过至少100次要把电子设备扔进泳池。对。我说如果我再看到一次这个iPad，它就要沉到泳池底了。对。对，但随后你很快就会发现，这意味着你得做更多的工作。对。确实。我确实把我13岁的儿子马蒂斯的手机扔出过窗户。
You did.
Drive, all of us driving.
But it was a real slow crawl, and I picked a target area where I knew we could find it later,
and I just chucked it out the window and hit this bush.
And he literally was like, what is wrong with you?
And he was so shocked that I actually did it.
And typical trudeiform we pulled over.
He's like, I can't believe it.
你真的扔了。开车，我们所有人都在开车。但当时车开得很慢，我挑了一个我知道我们以后能找到它的目标区域，我直接把它扔出窗外，砸到了灌木丛里。他简直就像，你脑子有毛病吧？他太震惊了，没想到我真的这么做了。就像平时的特鲁迪形式一样，我们把车停在路边。他就像，我真不敢相信。
burst into tears, went back to look for the phone.
He's like, I can't find it.
I can't find it.
I walked right up to the bush.
I'm like, here it is.
It's right here.
And so that was a great little shot across the bow.
What you're capable of, right?
放声大哭，回去找手机。他说，我找不到。我找不到。我径直走到灌木丛前。我说，这不在这儿吗。就在这儿。所以这是一个很好的威慑。让你见识一下我的能力，对吧？
Don't mess.
What I'm capable of.
But it hasn't been much of a deterrent.
Yeah.
So.
Well, Will Ferrell, thank you for being here with us.
We love you.
You're a comedy hero.
别惹我。见识一下我的能力。但这并没有起到多大威慑作用。对。所以。好吧，威尔·费瑞尔，谢谢你来到我们节目。我们爱你。你是喜剧英雄。
Thanks, you guys.
So much fun.
Can't thank you enough.
Very, very nice of you.
Oh, Willie.
Bye, guys.
Love you, buddy.
Bye, Will.
谢谢你们，伙计们。太有趣了。感激不尽。非常非常感谢你们。哦，威利。再见，伙计们。爱你，兄弟。再见，威尔。
Thank you.
Guys, that was so fun.
How awesome is he?
He literally is one of my favorite people in the whole world,
and I was a little star struck there for the first few minutes,
but, God, he puts you at ease, doesn't he?
What a nice guy.
You were Starstruck when I came on?
谢谢。伙计们，太有趣了。他有多棒？他真的是我全世界最喜欢的人之一，头几分钟我在那儿还有点被大明星震撼到了，但是，天哪，他让你感到很放松，不是吗？真是个好人。我来的时候你被大明星震撼到了？
Oh, sorry, Arnette.
Oh, sorry.
When Arnette was, yeah.
Sure.
Good for you, dude.
Good for you.
Dude, I'm just like, I'm a regular guy.
I'm very approachable.
哦，对不起，阿奈特。哦，对不起。当阿奈特在的时候，对。当然。真有你的，老兄。真有你的。老兄，我只是，我是一个普通人。我很平易近人。
Farrell is the best, isn't he?
I had the honor.
pleasure and good fortune to work on a couple of things with them. And they were some of the
fondest memories because most of the time we just screwed around. And it's one of those guys who you go,
oh, no wonder you're a superstar because everybody wants to work with you because you're one of
the nicest people in the business and incredibly talented, right? Yeah. He's got that, as you know,
you guys know. He's got that sort of that natural timing that you cannot learn. You just have it or you
don't and he has got it in spades in ways that are yeah he's got that thing that makes him he's so
费瑞尔是最棒的，对吧？我有幸、有幸和有幸与他合作过几回。那是我最美好的回忆之一，因为大部分时间我们都在瞎胡闹。他就是那种你会说，哦，难怪你是巨星，因为每个人都想跟你合作，因为你是业内最好的人之一，而且才华横溢，对吧？对。他有一种，正如你们所知，你们都知道。他有一种那种你无法学会的天然节奏。你要么有，要么没有，而他在这方面拥有极丰富的资本，在某些方面，是的，他有那种让他成为，他太
surprising too yeah always he just surprises you with stuff it's just awesome is there anything you guys
learned about him that you didn't know certainly about his dad yeah isn't that interesting
and all the sports journalism stuff that he was excited about early on right it's crazy i've i've met
his dad a few times and i guess i didn't really realize this dad was a musician i don't know how for the
righteous brothers. I mean, that's crazy. Yeah. I did not know he was on Saturday Night Live.
Oh, yeah. That was... You didn't know that. Wow. Mind. Yeah, no, you got to go back and look at some of those.
But you were, you hosted a couple times while he was on the show, Sean. I never, I don't look behind me.
I don't look behind me. I just look forward. Oh, okay. I was. So, I don't know how that's applicable in this case.
令人惊奇了，对吧？总是，他总是用各种事情给你惊喜，这太棒了。关于他，你们有没有发现什么你们以前不知道的事？当然是关于他爸爸的，对吧？这难道不有趣吗？还有他早期热衷的所有体育新闻方面的事情，对吧？太疯狂了。我，我见过他爸爸几次，我想我之前真的不知道他爸爸是个音乐家，我不知道是怎么为正义兄弟乐队伴奏的。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。对。我不知道他上过《周六夜现场》。哦，对。那是……你竟然不知道。哇。震惊。对，不，你得回去看看其中的一些。但你，你在他上节目期间主持过好几次，肖恩。我从不，我从不回头看。我从不回头看。我只向前看。哦，好吧。我是。所以，我不知道这在那种情况下怎么适用。
Sean, I'm very proud of you that you got, you got Will Ferrell to say yes. Do you have any sort of,
incriminating photos or does you owe your money or how did you how'd you do that i have a couple
um no i don't have anything i can't think of anything um okay all right guys love you guys i love you
hey guys i just want to say bang smart
肖恩，我为你感到骄傲，你居然把，你居然让威尔·费瑞尔答应了。你有什么， incriminating照片，还是他欠你钱，或者你是怎么做到的？我有几个，嗯，不，我没有什么，我想不出有什么，嗯，好吧，好吧，伙计们，爱你们，我爱你们，嘿，伙计们，我只想说太棒了